ein Viertel in der Hauptstadt katoum
östlich des Flughafens heute ohne
gefechtslamm die Bewohner nutzen die
brüchige Feuerpause um Lebensmittel zu
organisieren auch aus den
nachbarvierteln strömen sie herbei
niemand weiß ob und wann die Bäckerei
wieder öffnen wird jetzt ist gerade mal
Mehl Wasser und Strom vorhanden
an Brot heranzukommen ist extrem
schwierig
die letzten Tage war das völlig
unmöglich
heute haben wir Glück
es wird gerade nicht gekämpft hier und
Sie haben irgendwie Wasser heran
geschafft
in ihrer Not organisieren sich die
Bewohner untereinander wo immer noch
Wasser zu haben ist wird es verteilt
Medikamente gibt es kaum noch bewaffnete
überfallen geschlossene Apotheken auch
Krankenhäuser wurden angegriffen die
meisten Kliniken sind deshalb
geschlossen
der Preis für Kraftstoff ist explodiert
Tankstellen werden geplündert das
kriegsgeplagte Land steht erneut am
Abgrund
wir haben nicht damit gerechnet dass ein
solcher Krieg so schnell ausbrechen wird
allen war klar dass was in der Luft
liegt aber nicht dass das dermaßen
explodieren würde
cartoon unter Feuer die zwei mächtigsten
Generäle Sudans hetzen ihre
hochbewaffneten Truppen aufeinander
rücksichtslose Feuergefechte mitten in
Wohnvierteln Luftangriffe auf die eigene
Hauptstadt mittendrin die
Zivilbevölkerung schutzlose Geiseln im
mörderischen Machtkampf zweier Militärs
die die Alleinherrschaft anstreben
der eine abdelverdach alborhan Chef der
staatlichen Streitkräfte de facto auch
Staatschef und der andere Mohammed hemet
die daglow ein Warlord aus der Provinz
davor dessen mächtige Miliz für
zahlreiche Kriegsverbrechen
verantwortlich ist und er als
Unternehmer inzwischen Millionen
erwirtschaftet beide dienten lange unter
diesen Mann Omar albaschiert der führte
20 Jahre eine brutale islamistische
Militärdiktatur in Sudan den Bürgerkrieg
in der davor Provinz setzte albaschier
der Diktator auf zwei enge Helfer zum
einen Miliz Führer daglow mit seinen
Mörderbanden und zum anderen Armee
2019 wurde Diktator basiert durch einen
Volksaufstand gestürzt seine beiden
Generäle ließen ihn kommt fallen sie
inszenierten sich plötzlich als
Demokraten vorübergehend zumindest 2021
putschten sich da Glow und gemeinsam
wieder an die Macht
für die noch junge Demokratiebewegung
ein schwerer Rückschlag
trotz strenger Zensur konnte im letzten
Jahr in französisches Fernsehteam über
die kritische Lage in Sudan berichten
sie begleiteten Bürgerinnen und Bürger
die auch nach dem Putsch bereit waren
gegen das militär-
der sudanesische Dokumentarfilme Snoopy
Ahmed ist Teil dieser Bewegung er hält
sie im Bild fest auch wenn die Armee
schon vorab per SMS warnt sie werde alle
Gewalt Mittel einsetzen
Schlagstöcke Wasserwerfer
aber es weiß ohnehin jeder wie brutal
sie vorgehen vor allem gegen uns
Journalisten und Fotografen sie wollen
uns als Zeugen ausschalten weil unsere
Bilder zeigen was sie tun
die Stimmung ist aufgeladen Snoopy
rechnet mit dem Schlimmsten viele die
hier gegen die neuen Militär macht aber
demonstrieren waren zuvor schon unter
Lebensgefahr auf die Straße gegangen um
Diktator albaschie aus dem Amt zu jagen
gebessert hat sich seither wenig
Aktivisten wurden verhaftet auf
Demonstranten geschossen die Wirtschaft
ist ruiniert das Volk darbt die
generelle nicht
am Präsidentenpalast eskaliert die
Gewalt die Armee feuert jetzt in die
Menge
sie schießen sie schießen
die Bilanz an diesem Tag im Juni 2022
acht Tote hunderte Verletzte Snoopy hat
das heil nach Hause geschafft die Gewalt
sagt der lässt dich abstumpfen
man gewöhnt sich daran dass jemand
umkommt
du triffst morgens jemanden bei einer
Demo und abends ist der Tod
es ist traurig und frustrierend aber wir
machen weiter es geht nicht anders
ein halbes Jahr nach diesen Schüssen auf
Demonstranten zeigen sich die beiden
Generäle als staatstragende
Verhandlungspartner auf internationale
Paket der deutsche
un-sonderbeauftragte für Sudan volker
Perthes Lob die Zusagen der beiden
Kriegsherren für einen Zeitplan der die
Übergabe der Macht an einen noch zu
wählende Zivilregierung vorsieht das war
im Dezember letzten Jahres Teil dieser
Vereinbarung da bloß mächtige Miliz
sollte in die Armee eingegliedert werden
aber die Macht teilen das wollten die
beiden Generäle offenbar nicht
[Applaus]
die Folgen für den Sudan sind dramatisch
deutlich wird das Scheitern der
internationalen Bemühungen in diesem
Bild
1200 UN-Mitarbeiter verlassen die
Hauptstadt cartoum in Richtung rotes
Meer
im Weltsicherheitsrat räumte pertis
heute eines GBW nicht Hoffnung auf ein
rasches Ende der Gewalt
es gibt bislang von beiden Seiten keine
eindeutige Verhandlungsbereitschaft
beide glauben offenbar die andere Seite
militärisch bezwingen zu können das ist
eine Fehleinschätzung und selbst wenn
eine Seite gewinnen sollte der Sudan
wird verlieren
es war ruhig heute in ihrem Viertel in
cartoon kurz aufatmen noch reicht das
Geld für etwas Brot was ihnen bleibt ist
nur die Hoffnung dass die Waffen bald
ganz Schweigen werden